but i want to give you a secondary
method
so underneath where you've done this
right do a little rule off
um maybe you could label this as the we
went through the indefinite integral
that's how we did it
this is not the only tool we have access
to and um there's actually a more
elegant tool here which i'm going to
teach you not because you need to use it
but
number one it's just it's just cool it's
a great method right it's actually it's
more efficient right and you'll see why
in a second
and then number two it actually relates
back to can you guys remind me
just because i haven't told you all year
how much stats have you done you've done
a fair bit of stats
right have you done continuous random
variables yet
you've done discrete okay so what that
means is my second reason is
what i'm about to show you here will
anticipate something that you're going
to do
when you do continuous random variables
okay so the little subheading i'd like
you to make here is
using the definite integral using
the definite integral
now if you have an eyebrow raised at
this point
uh that would be justifiable because you
might say mr wu
how can we use a definite integral here
you need like some boundaries yeah like
a lower boundary upper boundary
there is or there are boundaries
actually hiding in this question we just
need to
find them park that thought for a second
let me explain how this is going to work
we know the basic shape of any definite
integral right
you're integrating something in this
case if it was f dash
right and we pointed out in the original
version oh we have no boundaries here
right so you're going to get a plus c no
big deal our default like our
formulaic uh conventional boundaries
would be called a and b
right it's like oh here's a lower one
here's an upper one what happens
when you are doing a definite integral
what would be the next step i'll give
you a clue
it's something take away something else
any takers f of yeah
f of what f of something very good the
upper bound we evaluate
we integrate then we evaluate that thing
at the upper bound and then we evaluate
it
at the lower bound so f of a right now
um
if you this might have been a while ago
but if you haven't heard this phrase
this thing is so important gets a big
fancy name it's called the
fundamental theorem of calculus it's
like oh
pay attention right this is a big deal
okay now
when i first learned this i was like
yeah great but i don't really need to
care about this thing itself because
it's just so that i can get on with
other questions right but actually
there's the reason why it gets such a
big fancy name is because how immensely
powerful
it is let me show you how um first oops
that's not the one i want that's fine i
want you to notice see the x's in here
in here they kind of they appear for a
moment
they appear on this next line once i've
integrated but then
as soon as i'm ready they disappear
because i put in actual numbers
like 5 or 18 right so the x appears and
then it vanishes it's just there kind of
as a
placeholder so as a consequence it
actually gets a um
to represent the fact that it's sort of
there for a moment and disappears
it's actually given a special name it's
called a dummy
variable you might see this appear in
textbooks they refer to this idea
whereby the x is going to appear but
then you quickly substitute
something else because i can literally i
can put anything i like in there in x
i could put t i could put theta
i could put anger i mean it would be
awkward but i could right and then i
would quickly sub it out
so therefore just stay with me right
what i'm going to do is i'm just going
to rewrite this line like so
a b and instead i'm just going to put a
different variable in there a different
dummy variable okay
i'm going to use u because that's a
traditional letter we use when we're
substituting things
tell me if i change this on the left
hand side
not a trick question what changes on the
right hand side
nothing because the whole point is it's
a dummy variable it doesn't do anything
it's just there to stand in
for a moment until i can put real
numbers in so it's still f of b
take away f of a is that okay all right
now here comes the magical move right
all i'm trying to do is set up
what my alternative is to this method
okay the magical move is
i can put in any a or b here that i want
it's kind of a point right any value
will work
usually we pick some based on what the
question tells us
there are some values here that i could
pick for a and b
that would be useful to me based on what
this
question tells me one of the values is
obvious one of them
is not does anyone want to have a stab
in the dark there's not many numbers in
this question so just have a guess
now zero is a is a common useful thing
because we like zero zeros of integrate
and differentiate nicely it's all simple
stuff right
the reason in this case i'm not going to
go to zero is because when i
sort of uh scan my eyes through this
question i'm like oh
no zero's really appearing at least in
this example okay
what i do have though is look i've got f
b f of a right
i literally only have a single f of
something
over there on the left hand side in
terms of actual numbers what have i got
f of one right there right
so what i could do is i could make one
of these
one and then i can just if that was f of
one i could just put a three there okay
so that's what i'd like you to do with
me we're gonna make a
equal one so i'm gonna write f of one
here
the other place that a appears is over
here as the lower boundary is that okay
so i'm going to integrate
from one to something okay
this is all still here okay
now there's a lower bound that's where
it was hiding i know it was not obvious
that should be a lower boundary but we
can just make it the low battery that's
fine
now i have to choose the other one now i
said this was not obvious
but i wonder if you can help me out what
is the end line what's the destination
i'm headed to
like the goal the question is f of
x that's that's the thing i'm supposed
to find right so it'll be really nice
sorry i just accidentally you know my
arm and i just got vaccinated um
what would be really nice to find is if
f of x appeared somewhere in here
right that would be really sweet it
would just kind of fall out right
now do you see i have this f b that's
just kind of sitting there waiting to
have something done to it right
what if i know it's a bit weird because
we normally put numbers
into our boundaries but x is a number
it's just i don't know what the number
is still a number right
so what if i made this this
x i'm going to write f of
x there's a takeaway there right
if i made that an x where's the other
place the x goes
just over here it's the upper boundary
does that make sense okay
now i just want you to make a weird
mysterious note okay
right here i'm going to ask you to um
put in something that is not going to
make sense until you get to the end of
continuous random variables but when you
come back
mrs lees will be like why did you write
this on your book and then should be
like ah i see where this is going
just write this into me yeah into your
book for me
if someone wants an explanation today
i'd be happy to give it to them but for
now
it's just kind of i'm just laying a clue
for you in the future it says
pdf that's an arrow it's a very messy
arrow
pdf to cdf
i'll explain later if you're out okay
all the pieces are ready
you're looking at this thinking what
what does this even mean
well now watch how beautifully now we're
gonna solve the question
and i'm gonna do it in half the space
and half the time here we go okay
uh i'm going to integrate from 1 to x
now f dash of u
i know what f dash of x is so f dash of
u i just replace all the x's
with u right so i'm going to write in
here
4 u
minus 1 right instead of 4 x minus 1 is
that ok
and i'm doing it with respect to u is
that okay
all right great over here on the right
hand side
i've got f of x that's not going to
change that's the thing i want
this is going to become the um this
we're going to make this the subject of
our equation at the end and i'll be
finished right so i'm just going to
write f
x there you know what f of one is
the question told you f of one is just
equal to
three okay
this question this step here i call it
the setup right it takes some thought
it takes me understanding you know
explain to you what this is meaning but
now that you know you can just go
straight here if i was actually solving
the question myself
in fact when i was solving the question
myself this was the first line i wrote
down
okay now let's do it okay i've got a
definite integral here i know how to do
definite integrals
i'm going to integrate this and i'm
going to substitute in each of the
boundaries
now lucky for you we actually have
already integrated this right it's going
to be
2u squared minus u
right 2u squared minus u so let's go
ahead
2u squared minus u there's
i've integrated it and what i'm going to
put in is
1 and x is that ok
now just because that's so easy i'm also
going to tidy up a little bit over here
see how i've got f of x minus 3 i
actually eventually just want f of x
by itself is that okay so are you all
right if i just add 3 to both sides
you're following so far add 3 here means
i add
3 there it's gone yep
now let's go ahead and do the
substitution i'm gonna be even lazier
and i'm gonna put f of x over here and
make it the subject it's ready to go
right what happens when you put x
into here two x squared minus
x i mean you hardly even need to think
just changing one letter for another
what happens when you put one in here
you get
minus you get two minus
one is that right yeah
yes so i'm actually this is this is here
and i'm subtracting
one yes no no no
i i haven't written i've just done the
integral right i've just done the
integral
and now i've got plus three is that okay
do you see where the plus three came
from
hold on a second i think i lost someone
some of you for a brief moment right
where did this where did this come from
did you just do another step usually the
next step or i didn't do this step
okay sure okay so that's fine with me as
long as i know where we're confused
that's okay i was putting in one
into here two times one
minus one that gives me this you okay
with that
and then the plus three is just hanging
around and then i mean i'm done right
two x squared minus x they have no like
terms minus one plus three
in fact if i were doing this myself i
wouldn't even have written this line
because i'm like i can i can do that
arithmetic in my head okay
so what is the attraction yes i'm just
showing off this point okay what is the
attraction of this method
two things number one i know we had to
do a bit of thinking
first right but you should never shy
away from thinking a little bit
so that you can be lazier later that's
the first reason right
because you can just look like i don't
have to do three separate
steps like it's like what do i do now
when i'm finished this
oh i do the next thing right this is all
just once you set up this first line
you just flick the dominoes over and
they begin right your integration brain
takes over
and then the answer appears right and
secondly uh
you will get two continuous random
variables and you will learn about an
object
called a probability density function
that you're going to need to turn into a
cumulative distribution function
and this trick right here the one that i
said was unnecessary for this question
is kind of a bonus
right it no longer becomes a bonus you
have to wrestle with this and i've seen
many years of students get really
confused this is a relatively new part
of the course
right um this thing here okay and this
is the move that you're going to pull
so let me go right back to the start
99 of you for 99 questions will do this
totally fine with me it works that's the
reason i showed it to you first okay
however it's really worth trying to
wrestle with this to see if you
understand what's going on i'll leave
all the working there
and if you have any questions about it
please let me know